>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Travis Hensley: Though Robert
Burns is most commonly known
as Scotland's national poet,
he also made a big impact
in the United States of
America during the late 18th
and 19th centuries.
In this lecture, Dr. Sood
discusses the complex way
that multifaceted cultural memory
of Robert Burns in the United States
of America from 1800 to 1900.
Please join me in welcoming
Arun Sood.
[ Applause ]
>> Arun Sood: Thank you very much.
And thank you all for coming.
I really appreciate that.
I also want to begin by paying my
debt to the people and institutions
who have enabled me to undertake
the research that I am going
to present here today,
in particular the staff
and everyone associated
with the Kluge Center.
As Travis mentioned, this is
actually my second stint here.
I was here during my PhD,
and I can't overstate how
helpful it has been both in terms
of my own research and also
my career development --
and also through collegial
bonding in the sense
that I have made some great
friends here, friends for life,
some of who are in the
room and some who are
in different parts of the world.
So to Travis, to Mary Lou, to
Dan, to everyone associated
with the Kluge Center, I just
want to say a big Thank You.
I'd also like to thank
the Fulbright Commission
for facilitating this
particular research trip.
I feel very lucky to be part
of a program that is centered
around cultural exchange,
particularly when we live in an age
where exchange between different
people from different places,
different cultures, different
countries, is so vital.
And I hope that some of
my research into Scotland
and America's historical
literary connections gives back
at least a little bit
to a program that seeks
to enhance understanding
between cultures.
Part of the pleasure of working
here at the Kluge Center is working
with such a broad range of
scholars in a confined space.
I am sure the Kluge Fellows
who are in the room would agree
that when you have the likes of a
national biologist, a religion of -
a historian of religion, a political
scientist, a film director,
working all in a very small space,
it makes for a very
stimulating research environment
and you get some great
conversations.
Equally, however, I realize that
there will be varying degrees
of familiarity and also interest
in the subject of my talk today --
the 18th-century poet and
song collector, Robert Burns.
So to ease us into this
lecture, I want to start
by playing a song that, perhaps
if you don't know the words,
you will know the melody
to, just to demonstrate
in a way how Burns's work continues
to be remediated and is probably
in the collective memory
of us all in some sense.
>> Should old acquaintance be
forgot and never brought to mind?
Should old acquaintance be
forgot, and days of auld lang syne?
For auld lang syne, my
dear, for auld lang syne,
we'll tak' a cup o' kindness
yet, for auld lang syne.
>> Arun Sood: That was, of course,
Burns's lament on times past
and old friendships parted --
"Auld Lang Syne," which
I'm sure you're familiar
with through it being played at
New Year in various locations
around the world, and of course
at New York during the
Times Square ball drop.
And in fact Stephen
Winick, who is here today
from the American Folklife Center,
has written an excellent blog
on "Auld Lang Syne"
which I recommend looking
up for more context.
I partly played it, though, because
there is a much-neglected verse
of Burns's "Auld Lang Syne"
that I think helps to frame part
of my big project as a whole.
In Verses 3 and 4, Burn's speaker --
lamenting on a lost friendship
separated by time, space,
and geophysical separation -- states
"We twa hae paidl'd in the burn,
Frae morning sun till dine; But seas
between us braid hae roar'd,
Since auld lang syne."
So here Burns's speaker talks of how
seas between us broad have roared.
There is a broad sea roaring
between themself and a friend --
and that sea, of course,
being the Atlantic Ocean.
And this is a good reminder for me
in one of Burns's most popular songs
that Burns lived in and responded
to what Laura Doyle called
"a transnational world of encounters
on the Atlantic periphery."
It was not just people
that moved back and forth
across the Atlantic Ocean.
It was songs, poetry, objects,
political thought; the list goes on.
So in many ways, what that verse is
a microcosm of is that Burns lived
in and responded to a
transnational world.
And it's part of my
project to reconsider Burns
as a transnational
poet in the context
of the United States of America.
I do this partly because for much
of the 20th century Burns
was often considered a poet
of limited linguistic range
and geographical significance.
He was often considered
a backwards dialect poet
who only really had
significance beyond -
within the borders of Scotland.
His international significance,
his literary devices,
his broader oeuvre was not really
appreciated or recognized critically
with the borders of Scotland.
So I am following on from some
peers and scholars and superiors,
mainly at the University
of Glasgow, who have taken
to reconsidering Burns in
a transnational context.
And I am doing so in the context
of the United States specifically.
So my broader big project
looks at the reception,
the literary influence,
and the cultural memory
of Burns in 19th-century America.
And it's the cultural memory
aspect that I want to focus
on for the remainder
of the lecture today.
Before I do so, I want to
say something very briefly
about how the memory of Burns
and the legacy of Burns continues
to be very contested -- arguably
more so than any other British
or even worldwide 18th-century
literary figure.
The popular legacy of Burns
constantly straddles these
boundaries between
history, memory, and myth.
And this often plays out
in the political arena.
So to give you an example,
the memory of Burns during the 2014
Scottish independence referendum was
continually squabbled over.
You had the Yes campaign
on one hand, who maintained
that Burns would have voted
for an independent Scotland.
And we all - meanwhile we
also had the No campaign,
who tried to appropriate him and
his works into their arguments.
Now this was, of course,
a highly speculative
and at times tedious debate.
And I think it's summed up
well by this poetic flighting
between the former UK Prime
Minister David Cameron
and the former First Minister
of Scotland, Alex Salmond.
[ Inaudible Audio Recording ]
[ Laughter ]
So though this is definitely comic,
it still illustrates the
continuing symbolic power of Burns
and his works in that these two
widely divergent politicians
and parties felt it necessary to
somehow enlist him and his works
into their arguments in order
to persuade their votership.
And in fact, the same thing -
a similar thing happened the
following year during the 2015 UK
general election.
There were voting booths in
Scotland for the Scottish branch
of the United Kingdom
Independence Party --
UKIP, a right-wing populist
party, that had Burns's -
lines from Burns's "Dumfries
Volunteers" emblazoned on it.
Meanwhile, the opposing Scottish
Nationalist Party had launched their
campaign on his birthday.
So once again, a repeat
of the 2014 referendum.
There is a tug of war, if you
like, between the legacy of Burns.
Now to flip back to the
19th-century United States,
the memory of Burns
was equally contested,
multiflorous, and complex.
The idea that Burns's
rise to popularity
in 19th-century America was
because he was a republican poet
and a friend to liberty had
been both popular and enduring,
partly due to the frequency
with which he has been yoked
with ideological praise
from influential Americans
such as Walt Whitman,
Emerson, and Abraham Lincoln.
Walt Whitman says of Burns, in 1888
for example, "There are many things
in Burns's poems and character that
specially endear him to America.
He was essentially a republican
who would have been at home
in the western United States and
probably become eminent there."
While in a written
memoranda on Robert Burns,
Abraham Lincoln remarked, "I
cannot frame a toast to Burns.
I can say nothing worthy
of his generous heart
and transcendent genius."
However, groups and individuals
as divergent as Frederick Douglass
and even the Ku Klux Klan among
many others also held their own very
idiosyncratic 19th-century
memories of Burns
that were simultaneously articulated
through speeches, essays, dinners,
and other forms of
objectified culture.
Regularly implicit in these
articulations of remembrance,
however, was the subjective
promotion
of group and individual values.
Where Frederick Douglass
remembered Burns as being kin
to an African-American slave who
had "broke loose from the moorings
which society had thrown
around him,"
the first Ku Klux Klan used the
recitations of Burns's "To A Louse"
in a - as a rite of initiation
and incorporated other elements
of his poetry into their
founding constitutional document.
Now these examples are obviously
very polarizing and powerful
and admittedly require
much further context
and analysis, which I will go into.
But nonetheless, pointing out such
deviations in literary appropriation
and memory unquestionably
renders Burns a worthy subject
when discussing the
complex interrelationships
between memory, history,
and identity.
To help us make sense of the weird
and complex commemoration of Burns
in the 19th century, then, I'd
like to turn to some theory
with specific regards to
the term "cultural memory."
Employed and appropriated
across disciplines as diverse
as literature, neuroscience,
and philosophy,
the term cultural memory has
become academically convoluted
in recent years.
And literary studies often
refers to how memory or knowledge
about past events -- authors,
events, people or things --
are preserved through cultural
means in any given space or place.
In referring to the cultural
memory of Burns in the U.S., then,
one might think of the term as an
umbrella for considering the ways
in which American society -- through
festivals, songs, ritual, texts,
biographies, rights, or otherwise --
remembered the poet and his works.
This use of the term broadly derives
from a reinvigorated interest in
and response to Maurice
Halbwachs' 20th century concept
of collective memory, or
"La Memoire collective."
Formulated in the same period
that Freud famously began
to introduce memory theory
through metapsychology,
Halbwachs challenged Freud's
view of memory being a resource
of the individual psyche,
arguing that it operates according
to social rather than a
psychological dynamic.
Halbwachs suggested that
perceptions of the past, or people,
are continually revised by
social forces that act upon us
and moderate our present conceptions
of any given object or person.
The dynamics of social
structures, families, demographics,
social classes, and religious sects,
for example, determine the ways
in which we remember the
past, creating a shared memory
and a shared identity
that might differ
from the collective
memory of other groups.
And it's this idea that led
Halbwachs to distinguish
between what he felt was memory
and history, where history
or historical knowledge about the
past is a set of generalized facts
that follow some sort of
fixed standardization --
say, for example, the birth
and the death dates of Burns.
Collective memory contains
a subjective dimension
and promotes a sense of
identity which is intimately tied
to a particular group
and its value --
which, when you frame
it in this context,
might explain why different
groups and individuals
within 19th-century
American would remember Burns
in widely divergent ways.
Expanding on Maurice
Halbwachs' model,
Jan Assmann has put forth the idea
that collective memory
might be split
into two further interrelated
categories: communicative memory,
which is based on everyday oral
communication; and cultural memory,
which forms when living
communication crystallizes
in the form of objectified culture.
In other words, where
communicative memory is articulated
by active participants, cultural
memory relies on symbolization
and requires what he calls
"institutions of preservation"
such as relics, books, statues,
and other modes of objectification.
Now admittedly the incisive
categorical tagging here
of communicative memory
being primarily transmitted
through oral means and
cultural memory as stemming
from objectified culture can be
misleading, partly due to the fact
that cultural memory can also be
preserved or inscribed orally.
So whereas, say, biographies
and statues of Burns
in 19th-century American might
be the more obvious examples
of what we would call
"cultural memory"
in that they were obviously
objectified, it's also important
to consider historically
significant oral accounts.
An example of this might be to think
of Ralph Waldo Emerson's
orally transmitted 1859 speech
on the centenary of Burns's birth.
Despite frequently referring to
his memory of Burns, it was not --
as would be the case for
a communicative memory --
a living autobiographical
embodied memory.
He did not know Burns or have a
firsthand account of the poet.
Instead, Emerson's memory was
shaped by existing institutions
of preservation such as
the centenary itself,
the Boston Burns Club, or
biographical texts on Burns.
And this comes through in the
way that Emerson describes Burns
as being kin to the armed
and privileged minorities
who worked politically in
the American Revolution.
Here, Emerson's individual memory
clearly reflects the influence
of wider social structures -- namely
ideologically tinted biographies
that depicted Burns
as a revolutionary
and the Boston Burns Club, which
prided itself on political idealism,
particularly with regards
to the recently formed
Republican Party of the 1850's.
Though Burns did make
references towards the outcome
of the American Revolution
in some of his poems,
the manner in which he is
fervently remembered and likened
to American revolutionaries at the
Parker House Hotel clearly smacks
of a memory source being remodified
into an idealized image --
which is directly in line
with Halbwachs' theory.
Moreover, though Emerson's
memory was orally transmitted,
its ceremonial communication
at the Parker House Hotel
effectively formed another
institutional preservation in that
his speech is to be remembered,
transcribed, and disseminated
widely for generations to come --
to the point where we sit here, or I
stand here, talking about it today.
Perhaps the most striking
competition over the memory of Burns
in the 19th century was
between African-American
abolitionist Frederick Douglass
and opposing groups and individuals
from the slaveholding states
of the American South.
There has been a recent surge
of interest in the speeches
that Douglass delivered in
Scotland during his antislavery tour
of Britain and Ireland
in the 1840's,
primarily due to the
continuing scholarly attempts
to recover the memory
of Scottish connections
with slavery and the Black Atlantic.
It was during this tour that
Douglass visited the birthplace
of Burns in 1846 and
wrote an essay titled
"A Fugitive Slave Visiting The
Birthplace Of Robert Burns."
A fuller examination of Douglass's
account reveals the extent
to which his individual memory was
shaped by social political tensions
and in particular abolitionist
discourses.
It would be a stretch or
even an injustice to suggest
that Douglass systematically
constructed his written memory
of Burns to bolster white
Scottish support for the movement.
Douglass was long acquainted
with Burns's poetry,
having purchased the
1833 Philadelphia edition
as his first book after
his escape from slavery.
And he'd later gifted it
to his son as a keepsake
over three decades later, in 1867.
Yet the rhetorical and
thematic parallels between
"A Fugitive Slave Visiting
The Birthplace Of Burns"
and his contemporary oratory
proclamations in 1846 still serve
to highlight a distinct correlation
between Douglass's individual memory
and the social discourses
that surrounded him.
To drive home the point, it's worth
juxtaposing a speech Douglass gave
in Paisley with his
account of Burns.
Where Douglass describes Burns
as being trapped in "the moorings
which society had thrown
around him,"
African-Americans were described in
Paisley as "clanking their chains
and calling upon Britons
to aid them."
Where Burns lived "in the midst
of a bigoted and besotted clergy,"
the Paisley speech condemned
the bigotry of a church that
"comes forward and holds up the
slaveholder as being Christian."
Douglass's description of how Burns
battled a corrupt generation plagued
by "a shallow-brained aristocracy"
also resonates with his protests
in Paisley against "the man whose
pockets are lined with the gold
with which I ought to
have been educated."
The theme of pious hypocrisy
is also implicit throughout.
Acknowledging the poet's alleged
misgivings, Douglass maintained
that Burns was "yet more faultless
than many who have come down to us
in the pages of history as saints."
In a similar condemnation
in Paisley, he remarked,
"The Free Churches do more
for infidelity and atheism
than all infidels in
Scotland combined."
Douglass's targeted attack on
the Free Church of Scotland,
founded in 1843 after the Great
Destruction, was the result
of Free Church of Scotland
missionaries accepting monetary
donations from American
slaveholders in order to spread -
basically develop the Church
and develop the congregation.
This partly inspired Douglass's
tour of Scotland, which became known
as the "Send Money Back" campaign --
when taking a moment to reflect on
that, it was truly an incredible act
of transatlantic humanitarian
activism
on the part of Frederick Douglass.
In order to acquire the
fullest understanding
of the social discourses that shaped
Douglass's memory of Burns, then,
it's crucial to acknowledge that
his written account was composed
at the height of his mission to
exert pressure on the United States
by increasing international
sympathy and support for abolition
and condemning the slave-based
economy which was continuing
to benefit the Free
Church of Scotland.
These ardent concerns and social
political factors permeate his
memory of Burns, as the poet
is symbolically enlisted
into Douglass's powerful
discourse on slavery and abolition.
Now the posthumous use
of Burns by Douglass
and other prominent 19th-century
abolitionists remains an
uncomfortable topic given the
poet's increasingly debated
and somewhat ambiguous attitudes
towards slavery and abolition.
Burns, after all, had signed up to
sail to Jamaica prior to the success
of his first volume of poetry.
And he certainly cannot be
counted among the most prominent
18th-century abolitionists
in Scotland.
Indeed, there is an
uncomfortable conflict
between a man whose poetry is
predominantly the egalitarian
and humanitarian in nature, and
yet who also seems to refrain
from any abolitionist discourse
and had proposed to undertake a job
as a bookkeeper on a
Jamaican plantation.
Either way, the discussion
of Burns and slavery
and abolition itself reveals
much about the selective dynamics
of cultural memory and
collective remembrance.
That the reprinting of
Douglass's letter functioned --
and continues to function --
as an institution of
preservation is clear is
that it's influenced several
subsequent transatlantic
constructions of the poet.
Maya Angelou, for example, also
made a pilgrimage to Burns country
and identified the poet as the
first white man who "understood
that a human being was human being,
and we are more alike than unalike."
Even in the 21st century, we
might then view, for example,
Kofi Annan's enlistment of
Burns into a global canon
of humanitarianism
with renewed interest.
Speaking in 2004 at the United
Nation headquarters in New York,
Annan described Burns
as "an opponent
of slavery, pomposity and greed."
Rather than doggedly
attempt to defend, condemn,
or verify such a statement, it
might serve us well in terms
of historical understanding
of working memories
to consider more fully the
cultural mechanisms at work
by the ongoing remediation and
construction of these memories.
To further illustrate the selective
dynamics of cultural memory
in 19th-centry America, we might
turn to explore an opposing and,
indeed, far less palatable
form of commemoration
in Pulaski, Tennessee, 1865.
In a ceremonial induction
for potential members
of the newly formed white
supremacist fraternity,
the Ku Klux Klan, Burns's
"To A Louse" was incorporated
as a rite of initiation.
The Klan historian Martin Gitlin
has described the process:
"A skullcap with donkey's
ears sewn on it was placed
on the head of a candidate.
He was then escorted to a large
dressing mirror the Klan dubbed
as the 'royal altar' in
order to recite a poem
by Scotsman Robert Burns.
The blindfold was then removed
to reveal to the candidate
that he had literally
been dressed up as an ass,
much to the amusement
of the Klansmen.
The embarrassed man could then
accept or deny membership.
Most agreed to join, with those
in the financially depressed rural
areas showing a particular interest.
In addition to this, the
first constitutional document
of the Ku Klux Klan also
reveals a Burnsian influence.
Printed secretly in the office
of "The Pulaski Citizen" in 1867,
the prescript begins with two
unattributed literary quotes:
one from Shakespeare's "Hamlet,"
along with an altered stanza
from Burns's "Address to the Deil."
In the verse you can see there,
Burns's original use of Burns's
"'rantin' - bardie's rantin,
drinkin'" is replaced with "ghoul"
to denote the white-cloaked
members of the organization who --
as outlined in the document -- were
to meet in dens under the command
of the Grand Wizard of the Empire.
In addition to the dark
canting [phonetic] connotations
of an inebriated ranting ghoul,
it's likely that the
stanza was also chosen
for its degenerative
reference to a black pit.
Now the question of why
Burns's poetry was adopted
by vengeful Confederate veterans
intent on venting their frustrations
on African-Americans
merits further discussion,
particularly when juxtaposed with
the simultaneous use Burns's work
in abolitionist discourses
of the period.
On one hand, the first Ku Klux Klan
initiation ceremony might be viewed
as mere comical farce
in its primary purpose
of entertaining existing
members of the organization.
In this view, Burns and his poem
may not have been considered
as holding any major thematic or
political significance in relation
to white supremacist ideals.
The recitation of the lines "O
wad some Power the giftie gie us,
to see oursels as ithers see us!"
complied with the prank
which culminated
in the potential new member
finally seeing himself humiliated
in a large dressing mirror as
others did -- dressed up as an ass.
Yet wholly reducing the Ku Klux Klan
rite to mere farce would be ignorant
of both the constitutional use
of "Address to the Deil" and,
more broadly, the extent to
which Scottish writers, imagery,
and iconography played a part
in shaping the identity
of Southern extremists.
There is much evidence to suggest
that as Confederate soldiers drew
on parallels between the
loss of highland culture
in 18th-century Scotland
and the loss
of Southern independence
after the Civil War.
This formed the mold for
the foundational identity
of various Southern far-right groups
such as the League of the South,
the John Birch Society, and the
anti-Semitic Christian Identity --
all of whom drew on selective
interpretations of Scottish
or Celtic history to justify the
defense of what they thought -
saw as their threatened
white Anglo-Celtic culture.
Ann Rigney states that one
of the ways emergent groups
confirm their identity as a group is
by celebrating and reinforcing their
sense of a common past or a memory.
Rigney goes further to suggest
that the sense of sharing memories
or having a past in common
is arguably a precondition
for the emergence of such
groups in the first place.
Taken as an emergent
group formed after this -
ashes of the e Civil War, then,
we might see why the
six founding members
of the Ku Klux Klan would draw
upon their perceived sense
of shared Scots Presbyterian
heritage.
The Klan's appropriation and memory
of Burns, then, was clearly embedded
within a much wider Southern
tradition really developing
after the Civil War of drawing on
Scottish iconography to articulate
and maintain a distinctly
white identity --
thus implicitly drawing
out the connections
between literary commemoration
and national or civic identity.
To edge towards a conclusion
on this talk,
I'd like to consider
the complex issue
of whether these widely
divergent modes of remembrance
and reappropriation might
legitimately be grouped together
and viewed as instances of
national cultural remembrance unique
to 19th-century America.
Studies and cultures of national
remembrance have continued to boom
in recent decades, partly catalyzed
by a rejuvenated sense of engagement
with Pierre Nora's
monumental seven-work volume
"Les Lieux de Memoire."
Nora pointed to how as a
byproduct of modernization,
national feeling is actively
cultivated and maintained
through forms of objectified
culture.
For Nora, by the 19th
century national memories
of the past could no longer
be orally communicated
through spontaneous
or lived experience.
Consequently, Nora argued, national
communities had to construct
and draw for - draw upon forms
of objectified culture --
or, rather, "lieux de memoire,"
which translates as sites or realms
of memory -- in order to establish
and maintain meaningful
relationships with the past
and harmonize collective feeling.
These "lieux" or sites might range
from ceremonies, statues, museums,
anniversaries, flags, buildings, to
outstanding literary individuals --
with the binding principle
that they, whether physically
or spiritually, uphold shared
memories of the past that serve
to form group or national identity.
Now Alex Terrell has suggested
in 19th-century Scotland,
Burns had become what Nora
called a "lieux de memoire"
in that the public celebration and
commemoration of the poet helped
to give Scots a notion of
the past and shaped forms
of Scottish national identity.
Burns essentially became a symbolic
figure, and his work became symbolic
in cementing national feeling.
However, the issue of Burns first
functioning as a lieux de memoire
for Scotland in the U.S. is far
more complex and problematic.
On one hand, we must acknowledge how
Burns and his works helped to cement
and articulate the
identity of expatriate Scots
in America and their descendents.
From the early 1800's onwards,
expatriate Scots attended
St. Andrew Society dinners
to toast the poet and their country.
Local poets preserved and
adapted Scotch language verse
and songs inspired by Burns.
And tartan or other
Scottish imagery was -
often adorned commemorative
events for Burns.
And in fact we do have
a couple of members
from DC's St. Andrew Society here
today, thanks to my friend Brian.
To another extreme, though, the
prevalence of American flags
at the 1859 Burns Centenary, toast
to the president, and assertions
that Burns fought for freedom
and American liberty might even
suggest a rather fragile case
for him representing
a lieux de memoire
for 19th-century American
national identity.
However, as my talk
today has illustrated,
19th-century American national
identity was hardly uniform
and comprised of a
plurality of forms.
The idea of Burns as a figurative
lieux de memoire in the context
of the 19th-century
U.S. is problematic
in that we might identity
within one nation multiple
and at times competing
layers of memory --
the most obvious example
of this being, of course,
the simultaneous appropriation
of the poet
by both Northern abolitionists
and Southern secessionists.
The 19th-century cultural memory
of Burns, then, was fluid,
repeatedly reshaped, and reflective
of multiple national
and civic identities.
And accordingly, I'd like to finish
by looking the some developments
in the field of memory
studies to try
to frame this a little
better and tie up.
The Yale historian and memory
theorist, Jay M. Winterd - Winter,
has argued that we must adopt a
more dynamic approach to cultures
of remembrance and to the
interpretation of Nora's theory
in transnational contexts.
In developing a wider vocabulary
for a transnational age,
Winter has introduced the
conceptual term "palimpsest,"
connoting a repeated
overlay of memories
that transmits variable
messages but are bound together
by an original source, thus
conceiving of memory sites --
in this case Burns as palimpsests --
as more appropriately fluid
than retorting to more rigid,
inflexible terms or
metaphors that fail to reflect
on the layered multidimensional
nature of cultural memory
in transnational contexts.
Consequently, returning to
the cultural memory of Burns
through the lens of Winter's
metaphor is a useful exercise.
It's clear from my examples
today that it's near impossible
to find one shared or national story
or appreciation or appropriation
when unpacking the poet as a
multidimensional site of memory
in the U.S. Yet equally, these
multidimensional memories
and remediations should not be
considered as entirely separated
or isolated acts given they stem
from the same memory source,
expose various conceptions
of both the American
and the Scottish nation,
and are bound together
by specific geochronological
parameters.
Consider, then, the multiple
modes and divergent forms
of commemoration outlined today
as forming a palimpsest replete
with visible but overwritten
layers of memory.
Today's discussion has of course
merely touched upon a small portion
of these palimpsestuous memories.
As the centuries progressed
and continue to progress,
new inscriptions would add further
layers to the Burnsian palimpsest --
such as the continuing erection of
statues, adoption and appropriation
of songs, or widely publicized
commentaries by notable figures
which were to be reproduced
and continue to be reproduced.
Pertaining to Winter's sense of a
palimpsest being reused or altered
but not erasing earlier
inscriptions, these instances
of commemoration allowed for
a diversity of interpretations
of the underlying simultaneous
polyphonic meanings.
Consistently, this
Burnsian palimpsest -
oh sorry, I'm repeating myself.
This Burnsian palimpsest, in
accordance with the fluid nature
of transnational sites of memory,
variously preserves contested
narratives, divergent ideologies,
plural identities,
multiple appropriations,
and contradictory national
histories --
whilst all the while retaining a
trace of the original memory source,
Robert Burns and his works.
And since I started today with
one familiar musical clip --
inscribed, I think, onto the
collective memory of us all --
I'd like to finish by playing
out another very famous melody,
perhaps one of his
most famous songs,
"Is There for Honest Poverty."
Now this song was in fact the
song which Frederick Douglass
and other prominent abolitionists
of the 19th century drew upon,
including Henry Ward Beecher
and William Lloyd Garrison.
Quoting lyrics from the
song, Douglass declared
in a newspaper article in the
"National Antislavery Standard" that
"Regardless of complexion, 'A
Man's a Man for a' tha.'" --
here evoking Burns's most
egalitarian of refrains.
So here is an instrumental
version of the song played
by my friend Sean Healy,
who I almost roped into come
and play for us live today.
But a mix-up in circumstance
means we'll have
to make do with a recording.
this is "A Man's a Man
for A'that" followed
by reel "Journey to Glencoe."
And we can call this
final inscription
onto the Burnsian palimpsest
before I take some questions today.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Stephen.
>> Well, Arun, thank
you for that great song,
and thanks for [inaudible].
>> Arun Sood: I wish [inaudible].
[ Laughter ]
>> Mark here.
I want to mention one thing.
I love that you had to have a sound
clip in there from David Cameron.
[ Inaudible Audience
Comments And Question ]
>> Arun Sood: Yeah.
I mean it's - in Burns studies it's
almost a million-dollar question
because - several essays that
say one thing or another.
I think -- you touch on
it there - with - I -
it's almost like complacency
on his part.
I think that what you can gather
from his work and his letters is
that you are dealing with a highly
sensitive, empathetic individual
who - whether it's
humans or animals --
stands to stand up against
abuse and oppression.
Why doesn't that extend to
slavery in 18th-century Scotland --
not in 18th-century Scotland but
the mechanism of slavery abroad --
when you had abolitionist groups in
Scotland forming and very active?
And he doesn't appear
on any of their lists
or their societies
or their meetings.
And then you have -- as you say --
the problematic mention of "the
coward-slave" in "A Man's A Man."
And there's actually another
reference in poems chiefly of the -
in the Scottish dialect that
refers to the "buckskin kai,"
meaning black cattle,
which is also problematic.
As for "The Slave's Lament," which
you kind of see as a counterpoint
to that -- a very empathetic,
almost - yeah, very sympathetic way
of looking at an individual who has
been torn from the shores of Senegal
to the bitter, frosty,
snowy lands of Virginia --
that's actually problematic in
itself because there is a lot
of talk amongst scholars that
Burns didn't actually write that.
And I mean you, of all people, I'd
be curious to know where you get
with this given your skills.
But for the new, there is
an upcoming Oxford edition
of Burns's poetry, and I think
there will be a lot of work going
into trying to establish
whether or not -
or who else could have possibly
written "The Slave's Lament."
But consensus at the moment is
that he didn't actually write that.
So in short, your question what -
whether I think his
attitudes toward slavery was,
I think is a very difficult
question because I don't think
that there is enough - if there
was enough evidence to say one way
or another, then it would
have been established.
And I think it gets into
realms of speculation a lot.
But I do think that - yeah, I mean
my former PI, Jarrod Caruthers,
had a note with me once where
he sort of said "Well it kind
of made me think about the causes
and the sufferings that happen
in the 21st century that
don't happen in front of us
but we turned a blind
eye to anyway."
And not everyone gets
involved in activism.
Not everyone gets involved
in activism towards,
say, chemical attacks or war.
Or, you know, we continue
with our life
and we continue what we are doing
because it's not right
in front of us.
We don't see the suffering
in front of us, so -- .
Is it a case where this - he -
had he been confronted with it --
had he of sailed to Jamaica,
he would have been empathetic?
I think it probably
would be because he's
such an empathetic person
on so many other levels.
But can you say for sure?
I don't think you can.
"I don't know' is the
question - is the answer, yeah.
I can direct you to a few essays
that debate the issue well.
And also the reference to the
"coward-slave" in "A Man's A Man"?
So Maury Patrick has an essay
on that has an essay on that
where he -- as you say -- says
it's not the slave in the context
that we think of, an
African-American slave.
It's a cowardly form of language.
You have to look at the semantic
meaning of that in the context
of late 18th-century Scotland.
So it kind of pulls
up all these things.
And I'll forward them on
to you, if that helps.
[ Inaudible Audience
Comment And Questions ]
I mean certainly - so thank you.
Second question first: Like,
certainly the short answer there
would be Freemasons in both Scotland
and America use an appropriate Burns
and herald him as a great Mason
and use him to cement their own
sense of identity and their sense
of fraternity with a
very rich history --
to the point where there is
a huge Burns collection still
in the William R. Smith
collection and here in DC
in the Scottish Rite Masonic Temple.
The -- how fleshed out was drawn
on, I cannot - do you mean, like,
drawing on Burns or Scottish
iconography more broadly?
For --
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
You mean like developing on the -
from a Scottish [inaudible]
point of view.
>> Right.
>> Arun Sood: Yeah.
I mean I think it does develop,
and I think it continues to.
Because if you look -
not necessarily Burns,
but certainly Scottish and
Celtic symbolization and imagery.
Because even, like, when
- during the second Klan,
when they adopt the
burning cross motif --
that's from a Walter Scott novel,
"The Lady of the Lake"
- that poem, sorry.
And Scott in particular,
his novel was a sort
of the romantic highlander
and the secessionist -
were very much drawn upon by people
who were bitter about what happened
after the effects of the Civil War.
Past the second Klan,
I briefly mentioned
that there you have the likes
of the League of the South,
which in its original incarnation
was almost an intellectual movement
that tried to establish that
the South was somehow different
because of its Anglo-Celtic
heritage.
And so things like the
Celtic cross was adopted.
It was considered ethnically
different
through Anglo-Celtic connections.
So the Klan initiation
ceremony, I see what you mean
by it almost undermines
Burns's poem.
But I think there is a definite
link there between the fact
that the majority of
these individuals were
from Scots Presbyterian descent
and so had it - as I was saying
about emergent identities, had
a common point of a past there.
Does that make sense?
[ Inaudible Audience
Comment And Question ]
Yeah. that's a good question.
To what extent does it matter?
I don't think it should
matter if you are aware of it.
If you are conscious of the
fact that your appropriation
and your version of what
you are taking from a symbol
or their works is derivative
of something constructed
that informs your own identity
but necessarily historical gospel,
then I don't think
there is any problem.
>> But -
[ Inaudible Audience
Comment And Question ]
>> Arun Sood: OK.
[ Inaudible Audience
Comment And Question ]
Yeah. I think that - I think
they care about him enough
to print a verse on the
first founding prescript
of the star-star - or
asterisk-asterisk, it's called.
I think that they are
familiar enough with him
and his works to appropriate it.
To what extent are they aware
of the historical nuances
I think is a good question.
And I think that more actually
needs to be done on that in terms
of looking through all the pages of
the "Pulaski Citizen" at the time
and getting some sense of identity
of how much they actually
cared about it.
I am working on a upcoming
project on Scotland and the South
that I hope to do more
of that kind of work.
Does that help answer it at all?
>> Straight [phonetic].
[ Wood Slapping ]
>> Arun Sood: thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.